Hello there! It’s finally here: the long-promised
video explaining relative positional
embeddings as they were introduced in
prehistoric times by our
ancestors in machine learning.
So, if you are not yet sick of positional
embeddings in transformers and want
more of them, you are spending your
coffee break with the right video!
Because well…, we did a video about positional
embeddings as introduced by the “attention is
all you need” paper, then we had a video about
concatenating versus adding positional encodings.
And there, we also discussed
learned positional embeddings.
Ms. Coffee Bean is now literally 50%
caffeine and 50% positional information!
Let’s begin: The “attention is all you need” paper
introduces positional embeddings
that encode the absolute position.
They encode the exact order of tokens,
such that the transformer is informed
about the sequential nature of data.
Otherwise, the transformer that is
processing everything in parallel,
would be invariant to order, meaning that
without positional encodings, its output would
not change after complete sequence reordering.
But what if we are dealing with other kinds of
data where it is not about absolute position,
but about relative positions?
Think about a graph, for example.
It would be quite arbitrary to say
that a certain node is the first one.
What would make this node the first node and
this the second?
That would be unmotivated for many problems
and in some cases, even misleading.
Then let’s forget about absolute
order and move to relative positional
encodings that are about the distances
between elements in either a graph,
or a sequence -- which is in
fact a degenerate graph, a chain.
A subset of the authors of the “attention is
all you need” paper, also have a follow-up
paper doing exactly this: they introduce relative
positional encodings where not the order, but the
relation or better said: the relative position,
the distance between tokens is important.
So how does this work? If you do not know
anything about positional embeddings,
first go and watch our two videos about them
and then come back. Don’t worry, they’re short.
The idea of relative embeddings is moving away
from the classical positional embeddings where
each token has its own positional embedding.
With relative representations, each word or token
does not have only one positional embedding,
but as many positional embeddings
as there are tokens in the sequence,
in order to describe the
relationship between them.
This is because relative positional
representations do not encode absolute
order anymore, but the positional relationship
in which each token stands to the other tokens.
So, let’s take an example sequence of 5 tokens.
In classical positional embeddings, each token --
let’s say x_4 here -- has one encoding informing
the transformer about the position of x_4.
Now, to best visualize relative representations,
let’s copy the sequence again like this. In the
relative variant, each token
has 5 positional embeddings.
One embedding for describing
its relative position to itself,
then 4 others for the rest of the sequence.
And to keep the same notation as the original
paper, the positional embedding
describing the relationship
of one token with itself is a vector w_0,
as 0 is the distance between the token and itself.
Then w_1, w_2 as we move to the right and w_-1
and w_-2 and so on, as we move to the left.
And the vector w_i takes the
same value, independently of
what token we are currently looking at,
because w_0 -- wherever we are -- says
that we are 0 hops away in the graph.
w_1 says that we are one hop away to
the left in a sequence; or in a directed graph in
general, we go one hop following outgoing edges.
W_-1 means that we go one
hop with the ingoing edges.
So you see, this approach is not made
only for sequences, but for graphs too.
Ok, great. For a sequence of length five,
positional embeddings should
range from w_-4 to w_4,
so we have in total 9 positional embeddings to
either handcraft or learn for this sequence.
These w vectors can be written one
under the other in a table like this.
Notice, that these vectors come from
the relationship or distance between
one token and the other so we can
use a pairwise notation for this.
The authors also experiment with clipping
at k, meaning that after a certain distance,
positional embeddings get the same value.
So for k=2: w_3 and w_4 all take the value of w_2.
Okay, but now for each token, we are stuck
with as many positional embeddings as the
sequence has tokens, what to do with all of these?
Add them all up? That wouldn’t be a great idea:
addition is complicating things even with
sinusoidal embeddings where we have just one
positional encoding for each token because
we could mix up the semantic and positional
information. With 5 positional
embeddings per token, the
mixing-up problem would be only 5 times larger.
Hm… if only we had a mechanism that given a token,
computes new representations for that token
in relationship to all other tokens ...
Well, we do have this, it’s the self-attention
mechanism! A clever idea would be to modify
the self-attention formulas to capture the
relative positional representations too.
We remember that through self-attention,
each token gets a new representation z
which is passed further in the transformer module.
Each token vector is first transformed
by a linear transformation.
Then the new representation for each token is a
weighted sum over all tokens, where the weights
are sort-of an importance score. So fellow
tokens that matter more are weighted more.
So here, where the new representations
are computed, we can add the positional
information! Now, the token representation
after the linear transformation,
is further shifted in the high-dimensional space.
This means that each token x_j gets pushed into a
subspace saying that "look, I carry this semantic
information, but I am also your 2nd neighbor to
your right because my position in some dimension
is similar to all other 2nd neighbors, ok?"
Great, now the new representation z is
informed about the relative position,
but the self-attention
weight coefficients are not.
Therefore, the weight coefficients also receive
their own positional push such that the importance
scores make position-informed decisions too.
So, what do we have in the end?
Now every token has as many relative embeddings as
there are tokens in the sequence in two variants:
one relative embedding for the values and one
for the keys to inform the attention weights.
And the exact values of the vectors are learned,
which kind-of makes sense to let the model figure
out for itself what the best balance is. It
would be quite difficult to hand-craft these.
And what did this whole thing help with?
Well, this paper has only experimented
with text, which is a sequence obviously,
and they gain some performance
in machine translation.
But word chains are only a flat graph and
beyond this, the method can be applied to graph
representations in general or anywhere where you
have pairwise relationships between your elements.
Because remember, these relative representations
depend only on how far tokens are from one
another, independently of whether we are
in a sequence or in a more complex graph.
But Ms. Coffee Bean, why didn’t
the paper try this out immediately?
Well, it’s called "marking your territory".
But there are other papers that implemented
this successfully for graphs too.
Anyway, another upside of relative
positional representations
is that especially with clipping at k,
this learned positional information generalizes
to any sequence length, which is also a feature
of the hand-crafted sinusoidal embeddings, but not
necessarily of any learned positional embedding.
Clipping at k seems a little odd
because with small k, it takes
away the information of long-term dependencies.
Now we can only store that something is close by
or far away, but we don't
know how far away that is.
But this is similar with Graph Neural
Networks where the best results
are delivered with a small number of iterations.
Many iterations allow for information from
further away to diffuse to your point of interest,
but multiple hops are not always beneficial as
it can aggregate noisy signals from far away.
So clipping at k in relative positional
representations acts a little like a relative
position event horizon which does not hurt
tasks which mostly rely on local dependencies.
Well, we hope that these relative
embeddings and the associated paper
are now more digestible to you.
Thanks for staying until the end of this
explanation and if you’re still here,
do not forget to leave a like and subscribe,
you know, to help with the YouTube algorithm.
Okay, bye!